how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU there has
been a lot of Marvel MCU information
that has come out the past couple of
days including news about spider-man
three big news about Thor love and
thunder including a new release date and
plot details Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness and even talks
about the Russo brothers returning to
Marvel Studios to possibly direct a film
and if that happened it is largely
believed that they would come back to
direct Avengers secret wars battle world
which is most likely going to be when
the Avengers of the x-men and the
Fantastic Four finally all come together
in one Avengers film and to top it all
off we have some news about phase 5
slate for 2023 so we'll break down all
of this news that has happened recently
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and you can also
follow me on Twitter for live updates as
well so unfortunately the coronavirus
has caused many casualties in the world
that we all live in of course the real
world has been severely affected but our
Marvel world has been affected as well
almost every Marvel movie and project
has been affected so far by the
coronavirus
Black Widow Falcon and the Winter
Soldier Wan division shang-chi even
Morbius and venom two have been pushed
back as well and today unfortunately we
have found out that spider-man 3 is no
exception to this originally planned for
a release date of July 16th 2021
unfortunately that has changed
spider-man 3 has now been pushed back
from July to November of 2021
that's a four month delay still not
insanely huge of a delay but still very
sad nonetheless sadly we can probably
expect that all movies in 2020 that were
coming out in the latter half of the
year are going to be pushed back
literally as I'm recording this
spider-man into the spider verse two has
been delayed their official Twitter
account just tweeted update from the
spider verse October 7th 2022 originally
spider-man into the spider verse 2 was
supposed to come out on April 8th of
2022 and now sadly there's a six-month
delay on the film and now to top it all
off Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness has been pushed back as well
Doctor Strange to multi
rivers of madness was originally planned
on being released on may 7th of 2021 but
now a sadly has been pushed all the way
back to March 25th of 2022 now sadly
these are pretty huge delays but let's
talk about some good news we have some
reports today about phase 5 specifically
the phase 5 movies that are going to be
coming out in 2023 this report today
comes from Charles Murphy from the
Murphy's Law podcast he's known in the
community for having good inside
information with Marvel Studios and
yesterday on Twitter he posted based off
of what he's heard what he thinks is
going to be the lineup for 2023 in his
tweet he said this is not a multiple
choice list for you to pick from I'm
laying out options based on the very
little I've gleaned the past two weeks I
can't know yet because things are still
moving so much but this is done with
some Intel Ethan says 2023 shapes up
like a blade guardians vol 3
Ant Man 3 movie I think you know option
B blade guardians of the galaxy vol 3
Ant Man 3 Fantastic Four see blade
guardians vol 3 movie I think you know
Fantastic Four now Charles doesn't
usually post too much speculation
usually he only talks about things that
he's actually heard and based off of all
the things that we've heard option B is
the most likely option with blade
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 Ant Man 3
and the Fantastic Four coming in 2023
now all of these movies are confirmed by
Marvel Studios to be coming out after
phase 4 most likely in phase 5 guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 has been confirmed
for a very long time now and it's
confirmed that as soon as James Gunn is
done with the Suicide Squad for DC he's
going to start on guardians 3 Ant Man 3
has been confirmed for a while as well
and at San Diego comic-con of 2019
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
confirmed blade confirmed that mehar
Sheila Ali is going to be playing blade
and even revealed the logo and then at
the end he confirmed and mentioned that
the Fantastic Four are also coming so
all of these movies are confirmed and
according to Charles Murphy they're
going to be in phase 5 and it looks like
they're going to be coming in 2023 and
that's
not that long to wait for a Fantastic
Four movie and it lines up with a lot
that we've heard recently about the
Fantastic Four in the MCU like director
Joss Whedon coming back to Marvel
Studios to possibly direct the Fantastic
Four film not to mention the reports
that John Krasinski has met with Marvel
Studios recently via zoom meeting and
his wife Emily Blunt had met with Marvel
Studios as well so if Charles Murphy
ends up being accurate were most likely
going to be seeing blade guardians
volume 3 Ant Man 3 in the Fantastic Four
in 2023 but we also have some other
great news in regards to phase 4 Thor
love and thunder has been pushed up by
one week it was originally planned for
February 18th 2022 and now has been
moved up to February 11th of 2022 as
well so as it stands right now this is
currently the new Marvel phase 4 slate
Black Widow is coming out on November
6th of 2020 the Eternals on February 12
2021 shang-chi May 7th 2021 spider-man 3
November 5th 2021 Thor 11th under
February 11th 2022 Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness March 5th 2022
Black Panther to May 6th 2022 and
Captain Marvel to July 8th 2022 so
currently that's the phase 4 schedule as
it stands but let's talk about more good
news yesterday we learned a very key
detail about Thor love and thunder a new
character has been added to the film
which coincidentally could mean the
return of an old character coming from a
report from the Illuminati com who were
the people who reported that Christian
Bale was going to be in Thor love and
thunder and also playing a villain they
reported yesterday that a casting call
for Thor 4 reveals an open role for a
supporting lead character named Zappa
Marvel Studios is searching for a young
black male between 11 and 12 years old
either african-american or black British
it also lists him as intelligent
fearless mature with a good sense of
humor
now while the name Zappa doesn't really
bring anybody to mind immediately from
Marvel Comics it's actually widely
believed right now that this is going to
be somebody a very significant import
tense and although we aren't 100% sure
of who this character is actually going
to be in Thor love and thunder we have
an idea the current theory right now
based off of the description for the
character being cast is that this could
actually be a reincarnated Heimdall
to many people's surprise Heimdall
actually died in Avengers infinity war
he played a pretty big role in for
Ragnarok and a lot of people thought he
was going to be in the MCU for a pretty
long time but I just Alba probably isn't
coming back to the MCU to play his
character since he died however a big
part of Thor and Asgardian theology is
death and rebirth in for Ragnarok hella
the goddess of death came and Asgard was
destroyed so we essentially saw the
death of Asgard and then Thanos came and
wiped out half of the Asgardians
but now Asgard has found a new home on
earth so it could be that in Thor love
and thunder we're going to explore the
rebirth of Asgard and the Asgardians
just a theory for now but we do know
that Thor love and thunder is going to
be a crazy movie in fact Chris Hemsworth
has recently read the script for Thor
love and thunder and while speaking with
the Philadelphia Inquirer he said it's
one of the best scripts I've read in
years
it's tyka at his most extreme and at his
best if the version I read is the one we
get running with it's going to be pretty
insane so a reincarnated Heimdall coming
back in Thor love and thunder doesn't
seem too crazy for a movie that's
supposed to be insane so there's a lot
to look forward to in Thor love and
thunder and then we finally have talked
about the Russo brothers possibly coming
back to Marvel Studios to direct a new
film according to comic book calm even
though the Russo brothers left with
Avengers in Game the Russo brothers are
always in talks about creating another
installment of the MCU and in a recent
interview they said we talked to Marvel
chief creative officer Kevin Feige and
Marvel Studios co-president Ludi
Esposito all the time at Marvel they're
all friends of ours texting seeing how
everyone's doing we get together with
Lou for regular dinners once a month and
there's always conversations going on I
think you know when we all land on what
the right project is for us all to team
back up on we'll jump in feet first for
sure so according to the Russo brothers
themselves they're always
talking to executives at marvel studios
and they're always talking about
possible projects that they could come
back to direct they just have to find
the right one
however coincidentally the Russo
brothers have already revealed which
project they would come back to Marvel
Studios for to direct over a year ago in
an interview with Collider they said
that after Avengers in game they were
taking a break from Marvel Studios but
then they were asked what project would
bring them back and they replied with
Avengers secret Wars and then not too
long after Avengers in game was released
in another interview they were asked the
same question and they gave the same
answer Avengers secret wars with the
Fantastic Four and the x-men headed to
the MCU to eventually team up with the
Avengers it certainly does seem like
Avengers secret Wars is going to be the
next Avengers in-game level event
especially when you consider that Doctor
Doom and Galactus are said to be the
next big bads of the MCU over the next
10 years over the next few years we're
going to get the new Avengers team the
Fantastic Four and a new x-men team will
have individual films over time but then
eventually everybody will come together
like they did in infinity war and in
game and that movie will most likely be
battleworld so in the midst of some bad
news we do have some good news to go
along with it but let me know what you
think about all of this and if the 2023
slate that Charles Murphy said is what
we get will you be excited about that
and would you like the Russo brothers to
return to the MCU to direct a film be
sure to let me know in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU for the quickest updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof